There's a shocking statistic
I want to share with you.
Latin America is home to only
eight percent of the world’s population
but one third of its homicides.
This is especially extreme
in the Northern Triangle countries
of Honduras, Guatemala and El Salvador,
where I'm from and where I live.
Just imagine the impact that this kind
of unrelenting violence can have
on a person's health,
productivity and well-being.
Especially because we know
that if we're exposed to violence,
this can result in trauma.
And when that happens,
our brain's stress response
actually shuts down core functions
like problem solving, critical thinking
and emotional regulation.
And it elevates the ones that we need
to protect ourselves and survive.
So this makes it really hard
to learn to make decisions
and even maintain relationships.
It can also increase our risks
of lung and heart disease, diabetes,
anxiety and depression.
So imagine what this can mean
for entire communities
when almost everybody
can be walking around
with unaddressed stress and trauma.
Then picture what can happen as individual
and collective trauma collide.
To make matters worse,
we know that exposure to violence
can lead to more violence.
Research has shown
that survivors of violence
can be up to six times more likely
to either be involved in violence
or be revictimized.
It's literally the definition
of a vicious cycle.
The good news is we know
that we can interrupt this cycle
by addressing the underlying trauma
with better access to mental health care.
The only problem is
access to mental health care
in these communities
is virtually non-existent.
So just to give you an idea,
in the United States,
there are about 270
mental health care workers
for every 100,000 people.
In Honduras, this drops to two.
So we're left with this classic conundrum.
We know how to help solve the problem,
but we don't have the resources to do it.
But what if we re-envision what
or who these resources could be?
I think we should,
because there are ways
to flood communities
with access to mental health care.
It’s already being done, and it’s working.
And I want to tell you a little bit
about how we're doing it at Glasswing.
We're training thousands of existing
government employees like teachers,
nurses, doctors and police officers
on trauma education and self-care.
We're essentially trying to create
a whole core of lay mental health workers
who are already serving
on the front lines
and can therefore step in and buffer
the impacts of violence and trauma
on themselves and
on the communities they serve.
We've trained health care workers
to be able to recognize
the signs of trauma,
to be able to help patients understand
what they're experiencing
and equip them with tools to cope
or refer them if they need it.
We've actually seen that trauma-informed
violence prevention work in hospitals
can reduce the likelihood
of revictimization by up to 30 percent.
(Applause)
In schools, we know
that if children and adolescents
have access to a caring adult
that can help them cope with stress,
their grades improve,
their conduct improves
and their resilience.
And in our work with police,
90 percent of the police we trained
actually felt better able
to regulate their emotions
and to deal with anxiety and fear.
Eighty percent even told us
that they felt better equipped
to help their peers.
I want to share a story with you.
Back in 2018, our Guatemala
team was working in a community
with really high rates of crime,
violence and stigma.
One of the schools we were working in
is actually a school where kids ended up
if they got expelled
or if they got in trouble.
So that's why Walter,
a 17-year-old student,
was really surprised
and a little confused, when Eluvia,
one of our trauma-informed
school coordinators,
showed up to recruit him and his friends
to work at the local primary school.
But Eluvia's from that community,
and she knew that if she could empower
a young man like Walter
to become involved and become
a school coordinator,
she could not only transform his life
but also the life
of the kids he'd work with.
So sure enough, a couple of weeks later,
Walter was trained and leading a group
of 20 little kids in a glee club.
He loved it.
(Applause)
He loved it so much that he continued
to show up every week
for over two years.
But one afternoon,
one of Walter's neighbors
ran into the school screaming
that Walter had to get home
because his sister
had been shot and killed.
Walter sprinted out.
And as he described it to me,
he felt his mind and body go numb.
Then he felt his heart start to race
and his chest fill with rage.
He knew who had killed his sister.
And he ran up to his room to get a gun.
Let me pause there for a sec.
Do you remember
what I told you a minute ago,
about how violence
can lead to more violence?
That could have been Walter.
But it wasn't.
Because he told me that when
he pictured his mentor, Eluvia,
and the little glee club kids finding out
that their role model had killed someone,
he put the gun down.
And that, that right there --
(Applause)
is where the cycle of violence stopped.
That's everything.
I have other stories
like Walter and Eluvia's.
But to interrupt and to stop
this epidemic of violence,
we need thousands more.
And there are great ways
to do this that are replicable.
We know that we can provide
more health care in communities
provided by regular people.
I’m talking about community,
and I’m talking about systems change
at the same time.
First, we train everybody
in public schools,
public hospitals, clinics
and police precincts
on trauma, education and self care
so they can better take care of themselves
and also those that they serve
understand trauma and manage it.
Then we train a subset
as interventionists
so they can deal with emergencies,
providing crisis intervention
and ongoing support.
And then we train a subset of those
interventionists as trainers
so they can continue to train their peers
and they can train other organizations
so we can have a growing network
of trauma-informed services
in each community.
The great thing is this model is scalable
and it’s cost-effective,
because we're working
within public systems
with people that are already there.
So really, we know that violence
happens between people,
but so does healing.
That's where it starts.
So we know the power
lies in people, in relationships,
in a community healing itself.
One of my favorite quotes by Viktor Frankl
in “Man’s Search for Meaning” is:
"Between stimulus and response,
there is a space.
In that space is our power
to choose our response.
And in our response
lies our growth and our freedom."
Our goal is to literally
infiltrate the space
in between violent stimulus and response,
with mental health knowledge and skills
so that communities can pave
their own way to healing and resilience.
Thank you so much.
(Applause and cheers)